I like that. Let me go to Kalsi from Colorado,
Kalsi from Colorado. Welcome. You were on the air.
David, good to speak with you again. Likewise.
Hey, so I was thinking about this and I kind of
want to get your opinion. I just watched your
video on conspiracy theories and I thought it
was fascinating. And while I don't, I, I my
personal kind of experience with it is with a
friend who was. Conservative in twenty sixteen,
but has then switched now to a libertarian, but
a conversation we had March right before
everything shut down was conspiracy's
linked to kind of the government with how
funding works? I know a lot of our stuff with
states rights, with in terms of libertarianism
went in there and especially and then when the
pandemic hit, it became of, well, we're getting
microchip on. This is we get a vaccine or well,
the government just the stay in and we have
to be enclosed. But I'm going to go partying.
Yeah, that sounds less libertarian
than conspiratorial to me.
Yeah. And that's what I'm getting from it. And so
I guess my question is. What way do you kind of
engage with somebody that is like, you know, they
can't claim to be very libertarian, like they go
to conference with like Ron Paul and like,
you know, say all that, but then they're
spewing all these other conspiracy theories
that necessarily correlate with each other.
Well, the two things aren't necessary. As you're
pointing out. These aren't necessarily related
things. We have to deal with conspiracy
theories the way we know we are best
able to deal with conspiracy theories, which is
ask them about the sources of their information.
Ask them how many people would have to be
involved in keeping that quiet for it to work.
Ask them how they determine whether a news source
is trustworthy, follow their conspiracy through to
its logical conclusion, whether they happen to
also claim to be libertarian or not. I'm not so
sure that I even see it as relevant.
Sure, that makes sense.
Yeah, I just think it was I find it fascinating
because she has this friend has changed
their political affiliation, but has still kept
some of the kind of wacky things that you would
see on the right is what you're seeing now.
So, yeah, I find it very interesting.
But I you know, the other thing to keep in mind
is I'm not saying libertarians don't exist.
They certainly do. But there is a lot of people
who claim to be libertarians or to or claim to
be libertarian or liberty minded conservatives
who will very quickly become extraordinarily
authoritarian when they see that the libertarian
path leads to things they don't like.
And so a lot of these libertarians aren't
even really libertarians. And so I think it's
always important when someone has a libertarian
awakening. Some people really do, but some people
don't. They just found a label that they
prefer while still being very authoritarian.
That that makes sense. Cool. Well, thanks,
David. I really appreciate your time.
All right. Thank you. Kelsi from
Colorado. Great to speak with you again.